Hi.
I'm Brad, the lead engineer on
our new InBrowser Native Client
development environment.
I'm going to demonstrate
how easy it is to use that
environment to check
out, edit, build,
and debug a C++ application
all in your desktop web browser
or on a Chromebook.
Also, with this environment,
you can even work while offline.
Visit this page to follow along.
You'll need to
install our new tools.
I've already done that, so
I'll go ahead and fire up
the new dev environment.
It looks a lot like a
Unix command line bash
prompt, because it is.
Running inside the secure
Native Client sandbox.
So what you do in
this environment
stays in this environment.
Let me create a work directory.
Our new environment works
like its own mini Unix system.
Files you create are retained
in local web storage, securely
separate from your
computer's main file system.
I'll download a zip file
containing my project using
a command line
program called cURL.
Once I have my project, I no
longer need network access
and can work offline if I like.
Here's my zip file.
I'll extract it.
Let's look at what we got.
My project uses a bunch
of different programming
languages.
The core application is in a
C++ file called voronoi.cc,
which is combined with
several C++ libraries.
These are then built with
NaCl's GCC-based compiler
yielding a NaCl executable,
voronoi.nexe, all of which
is driven by a
bash build script.
Voronoi.nexe is then
combined with some HTML
and some JavaScript, which
creates a NaCl DOM element
and routes UI actions
to voronoi.nexe,
yielding the complete web app.
Which is then served up
locally by a Python script
once again running
in the NaCl sandbox.
Before we get going, I'd
like to track my changes,
so let's create
a Git repository.
Then add all the files here.
Now I'll commit
the starting state.
Great, now let's build.
Oh, that isn't right.
It isn't building at the moment.
Looks like the problem
is on line 506.
Let's open it up in Vim.
We have a port of Vim to
Native Client, but fear not,
Emacs users.
Emacs is coming soon too.
The problem was on line 506.
Let's go check it out.
There's the problem.
I've misspelled "height."
I'll fix it.
Then save.
Compile again.
Victory.
I can look at the
diff using git.
I should really commit that fix.
Now, I'll fire up a
local Python test server,
using our NaCl sandbox Python,
and navigate to my test page.
The Python server lets me view
my entire virtual file system.
In the /mnt directory is
an HTML5 local storage mnt,
which is where my
home directory lives.
Let's go into the work
directory we created before.
Then we can navigate to the
voronoi directory, which
will load our app because
it has an index HTML page.
Here's the sample running
just on the main thread.
Kind of slow.
Let's crank it up to 32
threads and use all our cores.
Uh-oh.
It stopped.
No worries.
Let's debug it using NaCl's new
InBrowser GDB-based debugger.
I simply open the
Developer Console
and select the
NaCl Debugger tab.
Our port of GDB
allows you to attach
to a running application, but
will also automatically connect
to a crashing one.
GDB allows us to inspect the
state of each thread including
local variables and call frame
to help us track down bugs in C
and C++ applications.
Let's get a stack trace.
Bad things happened at
line 485 in voronoi.cc.
Let's go back to Vim
and check it out.
I see it.
Do you?
I botched "value."
Spelling is clearly
not my strong area.
Let me fix it.
Save.
Rebuild.
Double-check the diff.
Let's commit that too.
Let's look at my
commit history as well.
There are all my changes.
Let's give this
new version a go.
Works like before.
Now let's add some more points.
That's really janky slow.
Let's try our 32 threads again.
Much better.
Use Native Client and our new
development tools to bring high
performance
applications to the web,
whether your application is
written in C, C++, Python, Lua,
or Ruby, with more languages
and portable NaCl support coming
soon.
Try this tutorial
at the link above
or visit our developer
site for more information
on how to use Native Client
to supercharge the web.
Thanks for watching.